let's say that we've come up with a new
pill that we think has a good chance of
helping people with diabetes control
their blood sugar when someone has
diabetes their blood sugar is unusually
high that damages their body in a bunch
of different ways
so we want to conduct an experiment to
test if this pill really can help people
lower their blood sugar
so the first thing we need to think
about is how do we even measure or test
whether people's blood sugar is getting
lowered
well for our experiment what's typically
done is we measure folks hemoglobin a
1 c and you don't have to worry too much
about this in the context of statistics
but a hemoglobin a1c test is a way
that's typically used to measure your
average blood sugar over the last three
months and we have whole videos on khan
academy explaining how that works so our
hope would be that our pill lowers
people's blood sugar which shows up as a
lowered a1c
now we have terms for this
the thing that is causing something else
to change we call this the explanatory
variable
explanatory
variable and the thing that might get
changed by that explanatory variable
depending on whether you take the pill
or not we call that our response
response variable
so now let's actually conduct the
experiment
so what we would do is we would go to
the population
population
of
diabetics
and we would want to take a random
sample from that population of diabetics
a reasonably large one and later in
statistics we talk about what a good
size sample might be let's say that we
randomly sample
randomly
sample
100 folks
so
we randomly sample 100 folks from that
population of diabetics and then you
would want to assign these folks
randomly to two different groups
one would be your control group and this
would be the group of people who won't
take the new medicine and then you would
have your treatment group these are the
groups of folks who will be given the
new medicine
the treatment group now in some cases
you can just randomly assign these
hundred folks between these two groups
and one way to do it is you could give
all of them a random number between one
and a hundred and then the top 50 go
into treatment and the bottom 50 go into
the control or others you could use a
computer to randomly assign folks
now sometimes you might want to be a
little bit more sophisticated than that
for example there might be evidence that
someone's sex might somehow influence
how they respond to a drug
so what you could do is something called
block design
where let's say this group just happens
to have 60 females
and 40 males
one block design
you can randomly assign but you can do
it in a way
that you can ensure that both of these
groups have the same proportions of male
and females so for example if you have
60 females here you can ensure that 30
of them end up in the control and 30 end
up in the treatment but you would assign
those those 60 females randomly between
these two groups and similarly you can
do block design of these 40 males 20 end
up in the control and 20 end up in the
treatment so once you have folks in both
of these groups what you would probably
want to do is measure their a1c at the
beginning you could view that as a
baseline
and then over the course of the
experiment
you would give the pill to the treatment
group
and in the control group you might be
saying well we just wouldn't do anything
but the best practice is actually to
give a pill that looks just like the
real thing to the control group this is
known as a placebo
and the reason why we do that is there's
definitely evidence that when people
think they're taking a pill that might
help them that even psychologically it
can have an effect on them and sometimes
it helps them this is known as the
placebo effect
and not only would you give both groups
a pill that looks the same even though
this one in the treatment group actually
has the medicine in it you also would
not want to tell folks which group they
are in
when you don't tell them which group
they're in that's known as a blind
experiment
and you probably also don't want to tell
the people who are administering the
experiment which group they are
administering and that's called a double
blind so even the doctors or the nurses
that are administering the experiment
when they're giving a pill to the
control group they don't know that that
pill is the placebo and you might say
well why is it important for an
experiment to be blind or especially
double-blind well that avoids one any
type of psychological effect on the from
the point of the patient or from the say
the caregivers in this situation so they
don't kind of give it away they don't
tell these folks hey you're actually
just pretending to take a pill and so
that ensures that we minimize the amount
of influence or bias that might happen
you might even have a triple blind
experiment where even the folks who are
analyzing the eventual data from this
experiment don't know whether they're
analyzing the data from the control or
the treatment they just compare the two
different groups
but anyway you do you people take the
medicine and the placebo over the course
of the experiment maybe this lasts for
three months and then you would want to
measure their a1c later and then you
would see their change in the a1c
now if you saw that there wasn't really
a difference in the change in a1c
between the control and the treatment
group then you'd say well that probably
means that my pill didn't work now if
you do get a greater reduction in the
treatment group and you do the
statistical analysis which we will learn
in statistics and you show that hey
there's a very low probability this
happened purely due to chance well then
you've got something you could probably
conclude
that there is a causal connection
between taking the pill and lowering
your a1c level but once again you cannot
be 100 sure
and so this is why it's very important
for people to be able to replicate your
experiment
because what you'd want to do either
yourself or other researchers might want
to conduct the experiment with different
sample sizes in different countries and
different populations maybe with
different ages at different times of
year to ensure that they continue to see
this result